hello and welcome everyone
my name is jan pershko i work on the
wolfram cloud team
and today i want to talk about the
history current development
and the future of mathematics online
there is uh some overlap of this talk
with
a talk i gave previously about uh what's
new
in the cloud in general but in this talk
i want to focus a little more
on the history and the technical
challenges
involved in implementing notebooks
on the web yeah let's dive right into
the
the history of this project it started
around august 2010 so pretty much 10
years ago
at the beginning it was it was very
simple obviously there was a very simple
cell editor that didn't have any any
particular features it was just a plain
text editor
and there was basically bitmap output
coming straight from web mathematica
which this project kind of
originated from a bit after that there
was
you know some some interface around that
at least so you could manage your files
in the cloud and
started to look like a notebook in a
sense
but it was all still very very
simplistic
what happened then over time is that we
implemented a more powerful editor so we
added things like
syntax highlighting auto completions and
and many other useful editor features
the notebook rendering
mechanism became more powerful so
instead of just relying on bitmaps
coming straight from the server
we started to implement the full box
rendering
mechanism in javascript to have that run
in the browser
and a particularly important use case
was
to support manipulate it would have been
possible to some extent
to kind of have a custom implementation
of manipulate
in javascript with all its controls and
and various aspects but it turned out
that it was just
too complicated to replicate all of the
stuff that we already had
in wolfen language to port that to
javascript
so what we'd rather do is implement aux
rendering
in javascript so we can use the same
rule for language code
that implements manipulate it's just
that
it at the very end we render the boxes
that
it generates and the same is true for
the suggestions bar for instance that
also
started at the very beginning as a
custom javascript implementation
but in the end we moved to just
rendering the boxes that are already
implemented by wolfram language
functions
graphics obviously are very important in
notebooks as well
so after we had you know just a
plain bitmap output what we started to
do was
render vector graphics based on json
data
that was still coming from the server
but it allowed for
more interactivity and also nice
rendering
as svg graphics another
important aspect of the cloud became
managing your files in the cloud and
introduced this concept of cloud objects
in the wolfram language
that allow you to operate
with the cloud pretty much like you
would with a local file system and
move files there deploy notebooks
change permissions and all these things
there's also a lot of stuff that changed
under the hood over time
so at the very beginning it was a big
pile of cheek very javascript code after
a while it became
pretty unmanageable and so we started to
move towards react.js to implement
things in the browser
the nice thing there was that it allowed
for pretty incremental
adoption so we started to use react.js
for cells and boxes first in the
notebook world
and then ultimately we moved to react
for the whole
user interface also for the stuff around
the notebook
and basically just this year we
completed
that process of moving everything
to a nice react-based implementation
we also started to introduce a custom
javascript framework
to manage the life cycle and the state
of sellers and boxes
turned out that neither react chest nor
any other existing framework
did quite what we wanted in that area
just because
notebook rendering is is pretty
pretty special and challenging at some
point we might even
open source that framework as well in
case it's useful to others
another perhaps interesting thing that
developed over time
is a whole expression representation and
also a client-side
evaluator that can take multiple
language expressions
and evaluate them in
purely on the client side in javascript
code
to for instance allow for quick a
resolution
of certain dynamics in the notebook
so as you can see here our code base
certainly grew over time as expected
particularly the javascript portion at
some point
it overtook the java side
and yeah there's there's also
some css obviously and there's also some
rule from language code
that we wrote specifically for the cloud
it's actually
what you see in this diagram is just the
main repository there's
actually more stuff that's that's not
reflected here especially
in terms of language code and of course
this doesn't
even take into account any of the kernel
uh code that's
that's still running under the hood in
the cloud of course
so you might be wondering what's so
challenging actually why is it so hard
to
implement all of this in in the browser
and uh just to illustrate that a little
bit
uh let's look at an example like this
like this grid
with two items what you can see here is
that
in a notebook what we're gonna do is
line wrap things so
that both items fit uh into the notebook
according to the current notebook with
and we also introduce digit groups and
separators between them
to make the numbers more readable if you
compare that
to what the browser would do by default
you know in the built-in html rendering
if you just export that same grid to raw
html what we get is something like this
so it just looks completely different
there is no
digit groups there's there's no line
wrapping
to make everything fit on the screen and
it would certainly be possible to
improve that somewhat but to get the
exact same rendering that we need in
notebooks
we just need to go a level deeper and we
can't just
only rely on html and css but we need to
actually tell the browser
where to put everything on the screen so
we're really implementing
our own layout engine in in the cloud in
in our javascript front end
so if you look at uh the the browser dom
that's you know under the hood here uh
you'll see that
there is a bunch of html nodes that are
each positioned absolutely exactly where
we want them to be
as opposed to a single node that
contains the whole
number in this case that's at least in
cases like this where we have to do that
uh you know whenever there's a long
piece of text that would work just fine
in the browser and it's native rendering
then we we rely on that of course
and it doesn't stop with grids of course
what we need to support in in notebooks
is the whole
type setting and it's rendering so if
you have some
a little more complicated math like here
we need to render things like fractions
and square roots
and make sure that that all works nicely
by the way this is of course uh running
in a web browser right now so
it's it's a notebook on rule from
cloud.com that just happens to be
in slideshow mode and i could also go
and resize that
just to highlight that this is all
responsive
and and rendered on the fly on the
client side it's not like it's just
a bitmap that's coming from the server
and yeah maybe you might also be
wondering
why don't we just use some existing
library to render all this math output
because there certainly exist libraries
that do that but
it gets even trickier than that because
in the world from language and
notebooks you can nest things pretty
much arbitrarily
so like here i have this this math
output but i could
go and it's a little contrived but
i can do that in the language i can
replace the symbol x
with a button that does stuff and now i
want to be able to click that
to to print something and this is the
sort of thing
that just no existing library would
provide for us to
to be able to nest things arbitrarily
and not just
have have math output that sort of
standalone
one particularly challenging thing are
growable characters
you can already see them here to some
extent like these parentheses they grow
as necessary
but to illustrate that further on on the
square root sign
so you can see that it's the square root
sign
adapts according to the size of the the
contents as it should
and that's one of the things that a
browser wouldn't just
do for you and basically what we do here
is we have a bunch of javascript code
that
takes gloves from the font uh
deconstructs them
into their paths and then reassembles
them as necessary
to to construct a sign like this
that's how we render things in
javascript there is
a big open project that still still on
our to-do list that we're slowly
working towards and that's a full
typesetting editor
so what works right now is typesetting
in output
in basically read-only cells but they're
not editable
as such so you know you right now you
can't
place a select selection inside a
fraction
in a cloud notebook and edit that even
if it renders just fine
but there are a couple of ways to work
around that that i wanted to show
you and uh one of them is input from
based input so let's say you
type in some some code and then you want
to insert a fraction
we don't support you know control slash
and the various things that
that work on desktop but you can press
ctrl shift one
which brings up this little input box it
looks a little distorted here in
slideshow mode
so i hope you can see it somewhat what i
can type here now
is x slash y let's do x
y squared so the typing this
in as the name says input form
and then i press enter and then it
typesets
so this is a way to get typesetting
constructs
even though you can't edit them directly
in the cloud
and now i can you know if i want to make
a change i can just click this again
and and resolve it again
and of course this is fully semantically
meaningful so
you know i can do things like this
some computation around it and and it
will do the right thing
so that's that's one way to to enter
uh more complicated typesetting
constructs what's also coming soon
is a similar thing just based on text
syntax
so instead of input form you can type uh
text syntax which might be already
familiar
for for a couple of people and this
works sort of as
as an inline control inside of cells
there's a similar thing
that works on the whole cell level so
if i just start typing here
uh i can then select the cell and
press ctrl shift n on mac
and it will convert the whole cell from
input form to standard form you can go
back with ctrl shift
i in this case there's also evaluate in
place
similarly to desktop mathematica so i
could
select a part of an expression
in a cloud notebook press command enter
on mac
and it will evaluate the thing and
replace
whatever selection i had with the result
of the evaluation
it can also be useful to work around the
type setting editor limitations in the
cloud sometime
and again of course this has the right
semantic meaning so if i evaluate this
it does the right thing
similarly there's also a way to
take output and and reuse it elsewhere
it's just a little different from
desktop so if i evaluate this
unfortunately i can't place a granular
selection
here because that's something that the
the browser just wouldn't
wouldn't support natively so that's what
you also need
a full type setting editor in the end
for but what you can do is you can copy
the whole thing and we made that
particularly convenient
by adding clicks to copy so you can just
hover over the cell copy it and then
the thing is on the clipboard and you
can now you know start
typing a new cell and and paste that
so yeah these were a few ways you can
work around some of the limitations
uh that currently still exists in cloud
notebooks in terms of
typesetting in the editor
now i want to talk a little bit about
the the things we were just working on
over the last year or so and what our
our current focus is
in terms of development one thing that's
certainly
in our focus is graphics rendering and
improving the performance and also uh
the interactivity of that
what we're doing is uh basically
implementing
the whole graphics rendering pipeline
in javascript as well so far for most
graphics
we still rely on data that's generated
on the server and then translated into
svg graphics on the client
but increasingly we're supporting more
and more
graphics primitives and directives and
we can
render them directly in the browser
based on the graphics box expression
what that allows us to do in combination
with our client-side evaluator of
expressions
is you know things like things like this
pretty dynamic animation of the planets
in this case
that runs purely on the client side even
though it's fully
implemented in wolfram language so it's
quite a bit of code so i won't go into
the details but
it's basically just constructing
graphics on the fly
in an animator yeah that's
that's the whole project to to implement
graphics and
that comes with supporting dynamics
inside graphics
at a much better level
thing we're working on is what we call
interactive graphics
and the idea here is that for certain
plots
and perhaps other graphics we add
various interactive effects
to make them nicer to look at and nicer
to work with
so for a plot like this we might add
highlights of the nearest point and
also add drop lines so you can see on
the axis
where you're at right now and this is
sort of a combination
of things that happen in the kernel when
the
graphic is generated and corresponding
mechanisms that
take various annotations produced by the
kernel and
and turn them into interactive effects
like this
so some of this is hopefully coming in
12 2 and
then there's certainly more coming later
at some point also allowing
you as a user to to have low level
control
over what's what's going on in in terms
of these
interactive effects beyond graphics
we're also constantly working
on notebook performance particularly
loading speed
one thing that's been crucial for a
while is that we
render notebooks on the server side and
generate static html
that can be used to display something
on the client side right away as you
load a notebook
so that's you know sort of a trade-off
uh
in in terms of uh making things more
interactive
and supporting more box rendering in our
javascript front end
is that it also needs that javascript to
to to render stuff
obviously if you have to wait for that
rendering to happen on the client side
before you could see anything that would
be
a bit slow so that's why we also execute
that same javascript code
on the server side to produce static
html
yeah one thing that we've worked on
recently in this area is a
completely static initial
rendering mode of notebooks that allows
the notebook to finish loading even
faster
if we take a look at an example
how it would look before this is
actually even
without an html cache so what happens is
that
uh it loads the notebook it has to
download a bunch of javascript code
and then it starts rendering cells in
this notebook
and it's rather slow so it's a bit
frustrating to
open this notebook in the clouds because
it takes such a long time for this
little blue progress bar to finish and
and for the whole notebook to to become
available
but with this new mechanism that we've
implemented
it basically looks like this so this is
running a branch that's not
merged yet but it's it's coming soon in
157
and then you can see that the whole
progress
is much much faster and
i can i can already scroll through the
notebook it's all there
and it might take a little while for the
browser
to to update things as a scroll through
a notebook
but it's still a very smooth experience
so even if you have a fairly large
notebook it's safe to publish it to the
cloud
and it will render so just fine and in a
reasonable time
as you open it the way we achieve that
is
by not making every cell interactive
right away so particularly avoid a bunch
of kernel evaluations
to update various dynamic content if you
just open the notebook
but that's not a huge downside because
we can actually make things interactive
on demand
so here i have a notebook that also put
into this static rendering mode and now
when i start
interacting with it so i start dragging
the slider here
it will actually render the cell
on demand make it interactive and i can
just keep interacting with it and
move that slider around and this works
not only for sliders and you manipulate
but also for buttons so i can just click
this it
becomes interactive or select graphics
and and resize them
so that all just works basically
without having this big overhead of
rendering everything interactively
right away as you open the notebook
that's the idea of this static rendering
mode
what we'll probably do is enable this by
default for
large notebooks beyond a certain file
size and
if they contain a certain number of
cells but you can also
control this through a cloud object
option
called cloud rendering method
so these are a few of the things we're
currently working on in terms of
notebooks in the cloud but also wanted
to give you
a quick introduction to working with
cloud objects
in the cloud because that's something
that you might not usually see
if you just work with notebooks so the
fundamental principle
is that every file every notebook
in the cloud is a cloud object and it
has a corresponding
handle so let's say and you can actually
see that by evaluating the
evaluation cloud object in this case
it's this url here
and then you know once you have a cloud
object you can
do various things with it like changing
its permissions in this case i could
make this public or
anyone read by using set permissions
i can also publish something new to the
cloud using cloud publish
and and then give an expression in this
case manipulate and also
a name where i want to publish it to to
execute this
i get back a cloud object at the
specified place
and then if i open this it's
it's just this manipulate that anybody
could look at
and this by the way works both from
within a cloud notebook
and from desktop mathematica if you have
it running locally
there's a whole bunch of of other
functions to manage content in the cloud
and and the guide page in the
documentation that lists all of them
so take a look here if you want to find
more functions
one thing that i wanted to mention in
particular
is the different views or url types
of cloud objects because it it might not
be
obvious and it's it's certainly
something that we also need to still
document better
but the idea is that for each object
there is different
views and most importantly there's the
environment view and the object view
in the environment view the idea is that
you can
you can edit things and it's using your
your session kernel that's sort of tied
to to your account
that also means that you can only get to
this view
if you're authenticated if you have a
wolfram cloud account which means that
it's not
typically the kind of url you want to
hand out to other people
if if they're not using the cloud or
mathematical online themselves
if you just want to share something with
the world with
anyone else who might not have a wolfram
cloud account you usually want to use
the object view
and that's why that's what you usually
see in
in cloud object urls by default there's
there's no restriction to who can
get to the object view as long as they
have the corresponding permissions
but the only thing you can do in in that
view
is read and interact you can't edit
stuff and you can't evaluate
all whole cells part of the reasons for
that
is that this uses a different kind of
kernel
which might also consume cloud credits
if you go
beyond a certain limit and you enable
that
right now we can see that we're in the
environment view denoted by this env in
the url
but i could easily change the url type
of the cloud object
by either specifically dope the url type
goes to object
or
comparison environment then i get a
different one
one uh url type we added recently is
download so if you want to hand out the
url
and allow somebody else to quickly
download the file
um this is the sort of thing you want as
soon as i click this
it triggers a download of the notebook
file to my
local file system
so yeah that was a quick introduction to
cloud objects
and uh what you can do with them just a
few more things
what's on our roadmap for the future
certainly we'll keep working on
performance improvements and
improving robustness of the cloud
overall
there's for instance one idea to use the
wolfram language compiler to generate
web assembly
so that certain pieces of open language
code can run purely on the client side
without needing a kernel
on the server we're also starting to
make a big effort towards better
accessibility
for instance making sure that cloud
notebooks work well with screen readers
as we already saw there's still some
limitation
in terms of the typesetting editor but
that's certainly something we want to
implement fully in the future and
another
more technical thing under the hood that
that we're starting to work on
is to move the clouds to containers and
kubernetes that was
a quick introduction to the cloud
to its history and
some of the challenges that we're facing
some of the things we're currently
working on
if you want to learn more about
what's going into each release please
take a look at our release notes that we
publish
for each release i'm also happy that we
finally have
a list of supported and unsupported
wolverine language functions in the
cloud
so if you ever wonder whether something
is supported
or not supported yet in the cloud then
take a look at this document
and particularly if you want to know
more about cloud notebooks
and the things that that are going on
under the hood
then take a look at these cloud
notebooks implementation notes
please feel free to get in touch via
email or reach out
on community and
yeah thank you for listening
i'll address uh ita's question first
does convert to standard from work on
less than a whole cell
and relationship to shift control one um
i guess it should i'm not sure if it
does right now we should we should try
that
but i don't see a reason why it
shouldn't
so that is
basically another way to do a very
similar thing
uh i think the main reason for this
other
control was to have something that's
uh familiar you know it's similar to
this
upcoming tech input and also control
equals in a sense
and it also makes it a bit more
discoverable in the menu
uh you can go you know insert this this
input form
[Music]
type input uh but i don't know
the principle is certainly very similar
to the to the whole cell
transformation uh
john uh do you really want to talk about
collaborative editing i did just
allow you to talk as well so i mean
i'd say the the the big question is
should we focus on collaborative editing
or
should we do a typesetting editor first
i mean there is somewhat related and
then some of the groundwork will be
applicable to both but uh
then we have to decide which is more
important and
i think the the reasoning so far has
been that we might get collaborative
editing
at least in a in some limited form
uh through a different mechanism similar
to the
to the chat framework basically you know
or using the
the channel framework um
so it wouldn't be a full-blown
collaborative editor that that supports
uh you know going down to very granular
level
and and uh
yeah being able to to have the you know
have multiple people
editing the same cell at the same time
for instance that probably wouldn't work
um but but some simple form
could maybe be be made to work
with some high level implementation
um while sort of the the core
uh or the focus of the core
notebook uh work would would be on the
type setting editor um
that was one of our considerations so
depends a bit uh i did the you know that
channel
and chat framework thing that also
depends on service links
uh so that's that's a low level thing
we'll need
in the cloud first but once we have that
then
uh there is a good chance it could just
work basically
um but yeah the
implementing the the
the full editor with with live
collaboration that would be a
long-term project so i asked my question
in
in in the in the chat does and so maybe
you answered it while i was fighting
with browsers but
that's okay
but uh yeah yeah and i think it's really
just the four of us so
we can just talk about it again i see
it john andrea matthew
uh i assume nobody else is here and
there's any questions
so that then we might as well talk about
that again um
[Music]
yeah it's certainly very similar um
i don't see a reason why a converted
standard form shouldn't work for parts
of a cell
so if it doesn't then we should make
that work
um i think there's still some
some reason why we might want this this
shift control one
input since it's just more discoverable
in the in the menu
and it's just similar to the tech based
input as well
i see yeah it seems i mean if
if you have re really convert to
standard form and convert to input form
you know this seems kind of redundant
yeah to some extent it might be
i think it's really mostly about
discoverability and
uh
yeah something a little more familiar
maybe
does it does it work on desktop to
convert parts of the cell
yes absolutely i mean they have to be it
has to be a full expression
right you can't convert part of an
expression
but as long as you select and i i i
suppose
that that is sort of the advantage of
the
that might be a slight advantage of the
shift control one that you always know
what part is being converted um
which i guess you would because you'd
need to select it first before you did
shift control
and anyway but you know then there's no
sort of i
accidentally selected one comma too much
or
something like that right and because
you've typed right in
so if you've typed something extra it's
your fault for typing it in rather than
uh you know bad ui
but yeah it just i mean like the tech
thing is
they're sort of i think value added just
because really there isn't
it's it's right it's this little foreign
thing
but the shift control one thing just
seems
you know i guess it rubs me the wrong
way
got it yeah
[Music]
it is it's more redundant than
the tech thing yeah and i just tried it
in the cloud
it does not work around it right now it
seems i mean i can
i can press it compress uh ctrl shift
n without selecting the whole cell but
then it still
applies to the whole cell it seems okay
so that's something you should look into
okay cool well nice talk uh i'm gonna go
grab some lunch before
the the ui
uh the front the front end meet up
if you wanna don't know if you'll go
hang out there too
of course yep that's on my list
thank you dad bye uh
i think we can wrap up here as well
right okay
great thank you bye-bye
you